[Música]
ver na minha mãe de graciano e eu vim
explicar um pouquinho que o economista
vem fazendo no mundo da inovação de
tecnologias trabalhando desde pessoas da
moda biotecnologia estas sem ser
exatamente uma pessoa técnica e mais do
que isso venha falar sobre todo o
empreendedorismo que a gente hoje vem
ouvir falar muito ea gente não sabe
muito bem o que é e como faço pra gente
vai pra mim a coisa mais importante
sobre empreendedorismo a gente tem idéia
de como a gente aprende na vida e aí pra
gente começar
queria convidar vocês a fazer nesses
imaginação junto comigo lembra quando a
gente é criança que a gente vê uma atriz
o ator uma cantora e aquelas pessoas na
televisão a gente ficar quando eu
crescer quero ser igual àquelas pessoas
oponente de nossos pais voz pai nossa
mãe ea gente fica pensando em quando eu
crescer quero ser um pouquinho parecido
com eles
isso acontece o tempo inteiro um exemplo
é o michael phelps é eleito falou assim
sobre natal que é uma pessoa que eu não
aprendeu a nadar mas eu conheço muitas
pessoas que são atletas e que por causa
de atletas tipo michael phelps quiseram
aprender a nadar e pedir aos seus pais
para entrar numa natação e aos poucos as
pessoas realmente foram pra andar talvez
até competiram e viraram realmente
nadadores
eles não viram a marca phelps mas sonhar
a nadar e viraram nadadores isso
acontece o tempo inteiro
e aí eu pergunto pra vocês o que
acontece com as crianças sonhadoras à
medida que elas vão crescendo porque
essas crianças sonhadoras à medida que
elas vão virando adultos elas se tornam
adultos frágeis como baixa autoestima e
muitas vezes adultos doentes
confesso que isso aconteceu comigo em
algum momento que eu não sei explicar
muito bem qual as expectativas que
tinham sobre mim as expectativas que eu
tinha sobre mim me deixaram doente
eu tinha certeza que era uma pessoa
queria você é capaz de executar nada
é não tinha certeza que eu nunca
consegui fazer nada assinado ao ponto de
eu ir ao supermercado e ter a certeza de
que não ia conseguir voltar contra
alguma coisa de errado mesmo caminho que
se tratava de mim é óbvio que alguma
coisa dá errado e aí eu me tornei uma
pessoa depressiva
isso acontece o tempo inteiro
expectativas que às vezes a gente cria
vão fazendo com que aquela criança aos
poucos vai deixando de sonhar e deixam
de sonhar deixando de ganhar e vocês já
fizeram essa pergunta que vocês queriam
ser quando vocês eram crianças
o que vocês querem ser agora também é é
a gente lembra universidade né e aí
coisas que eu me lembre se encolher um
pouco mais nova uma prova edital que
fazer o resto da vida passar em uma
universidade está o que fazer para o
resto da vida as expectativas que tinha
sobre minhas opiniões que tinha sobre a
moda que eu era e onde está o queria ser
o resto da vida
não sei se vocês já pararam para pensar
mas nem todo discernimento disse a
verdade
o fato da opinião que as pessoas têm
opinião sobre você diz é muito pouco
sobre a pessoa que você realmente é
e é justamente por dizer muito pouco
sobre a pessoa que a gente realmente é
eu também fui tentando me libertar e
descobrir outras coisas mas mais do que
isso foi tentado lutar contra essas
vozinhas que a gente vai ouvir vai
tomando tudo como verdade pra sair dessa
o que como o jovem que já formou faz né
ela tentou procurar um trabalho e
emprego mas quando a gente está nessa
situação
a gente não consegue procurar um
trabalho assim o emprego de verdade
porque a gente já sabe que a gente quer
e fala a gente não tem nem idéia do que
a gente quer a gente não consegue
convencer ninguém de que talvez hoje
seja uma boa pessoa para realizar aquele
trabalho sabendo disso eu fui procurar
outras formas de trabalho e fui fazer um
trabalho voluntário
passei numa organização e nessa
organização
tudo o que eu mais gostava nela era tudo
que me fazia querer embora todos os dias
as pessoas eram completamente diferente
de mim ela tinha os olhos completamente
diferente dos meus alas
vitórias conta histórias completamente
diferente das linhas e mais do que isso
ela queria uma coisa muito diferente de
mim porque eu estava naquela situação
depressiva que eu ia fazer aquelas
pessoas todos os dias
e aí gente diferente é diferente mesmo
assim diferente de história e trajetória
de tudo mas uma coisa que eu encontrei
nessa organização foi que mais do que
nós somos pessoas diferentes
lá a gente trabalhava pelo mesmo
objetivo era uma mãe que trabalha
fazendo intercâmbio de experiências
lideranças através de intercâmbio mas
internamente também a gente promove essa
experiência liderança e aí foi a
primeira vez que entende que tanto
empresas e quantas pessoas quando a
gente tem mais ou menos uma idéia de
para onde a gente quer dr
a gente normalmente começa a caminhar
para chegar lá é principalmente de
grandes empresas nossa empresa é muito
grande
provavelmente alguém sonhou e planejou
que aquele negócio é ser e trabalhou com
aquele negócio se e aí a gente lá a
gente também tinha esses momentos assim
de reflexão e de autoconhecimento e aí
eu comecei a perguntar sobre quem era
quem era amanda o que eu tinha ficado
daquele jeito e como é que eu ia fazer
para melhorar e procurar de mim na minha
saúde já se perguntaram quem são vocês
que 24 horas todos nós temos inclusive
as 24 horas de você sem planejar direito
sem pensar direito que vocês estão
fazendo se já pararam para pensar quem
são vocês
e aí foi quando encontrei o tal do
empreendedorismo
eu tive a oportunidade ao longo do meu
trabalho também tem o poder de trabalhar
com algumas startup negócios
eu não sabia o que era nada disso e
lamento não sabia o que era nada disso e
me deparei com mando como a comunidade
chama são pedro paulo jogam falar de
joão pedro vale ainda não viu depois
pesquisa é muito interessante mas não é
só o são pedro vale é que a comunidade
belo horizonte de startup as outras
comunidades pelo país afora quero fazer
coisas diferentes coisas interessantes e
quando me deparei com essa realidade eu
decidi trabalhar com isso
mas mais do que trabalhar com isso eu
decidi vir
ver o empreendedorismo e aí eu fiquei
pensando legal as pessoas estão a o que
eu preciso estudar enquanto formado em
economia que eu não sei que a faculdade
não me ensinou
quais são as referências nesse mercado
quem mais eu preciso conhecer equilíbrio
preciso ler que tipo de testes assistir
que tipo de palestra e com a experiência
é preciso ter de que ela fala só de
emprego é aonde eu preciso respirar com
as pessoas é preciso ter contato que eu
preciso fazer e aí eu também descobri
que o google não só a faixa de busca
assim com algumas outras coisas que
estão no nosso dia a dia ea gente acha
que é apenas um celular a gente acha que
apenas uma roupa mas na verdade existem
negócios e muitas coisas por trás disso
e percebendo que isso acontecia eu tomei
uma decisão
eu decidi tornar a minha vida a minha
estava muito fácil até parece que foi
muito simples essa tomada de decisão ea
como é que se faz
de onde você tira as idéias do mais há
um tempo atrás eu me deparei com uma
instituição de ensino que chama mais
vale
e aí com eles aprendi sobre blues jogam
falar sobre gols
é eu vou tomar aqui um tempinho de vocês
e quero todo 15 uma lente racino comigo
vou explicar para vocês com o que ela é
modelo de fácil assim
as gruas todo mundo conhece
as drogas são aquelas verdades que não
são verdade para todo mundo mas que dita
mais ou menos a forma como a gente vive
exemplo o homem não chora
mulher tem que casar a mulher cuida dos
filhos se você agir desse jeito você vai
ser um horror para a nossa família a
você é desse jeito
essas são as blues elas estão mais ou
menos a forma como a gente vai viver ea
gente não percebe
elas ditam tanto a forma como a gente
vai vivendo que tanto na televisão
quanto as redes sociais fazem isso com a
gente o tempo inteiro
está todo mundo feliz nas redes sociais
as pessoas estão 100% feliz nas redes
sociais e se eu não estou feliz é porque
provavelmente a minha vida péssima eu
sou o pior ser humano no planeta terra
confesso que às vezes eu tenho a
sensação que você tem essa sensação
e aí o que eu aprendi com eles é que
quando a gente fala dessas regras
a gente esquece de falar sobre a gente
não está falando de mim tá falando de
vocês
e aí a gente precisa entender que nem
todas as regras são para todo mundo
a vida é única a minha vida é única ea
vida de vocês também é única
por isso eles dão a dica durante v de
acordo com três pilares é o que me
apresentar para vocês
o primeiro pilar que a gente precisa
refletir é o pilar das experiências e eu
fui pensar um pouquinho quais eram as
experiências que eu queria viver mais
reflita que tipo de experiência você
quer ver
eu também fui pensar que tipo de
trabalho e ocupação eu queria ter
eu estou falando de emprego que tipo de
trabalho
eu queria apertar um botão todo dia eu
queria mandar um e mail todo dia eu
queria ajudar pessoas com seus negócios
do dia
que tipo de trabalho queria ter eu
também fui pensando com qual tipo de
pessoa eu queria aprender com essas
pessoas eu quero ter contato com as
pessoas eu queria ouvir falar e aí eu
fui eu entendi com eles e quando a gente
fala de experiência a gente fala sobre
pensar tudo e sonhar tudo que a gente
pode fazer mas vai jogar quando a gente
é criança ela todos os dias a seguir
sonhando e viver sonhar e aí não é só
sonhar é sonhar e realizar medida que as
coisas são possíveis as oportunidades
aparecem
o segundo pilar é o pilar do crescimento
sabe quando a gente vê um negócio uma
empresa aquela empresa tem um plano de
crescimento
as pessoas pensaram que a empresa pode
crescer quais são as métricas de sucesso
o que elas entendem como um sucesso já
pararam para pensar qual é o plano de
crescimento de vocês é que vão fazer
depois que saí daqui tem que surfar vão
fazer depois que se formarem e depois e
depois eu vou pensar qual é o plano de
crescimento e o que entendia como
sucesso que talvez sucesso pra mim não
seja chegar lá talvez pra você sucesso
não seja chegar
e depois eu pensei que ele aprendeu a
pensar em como eu aprender eu entrar no
curso eu ia ler livros e e pedir ajuda
atrás de quem que eu ia e como ia fazer
esse meu crescimento acontecer e mais do
que isso que tipo de pessoa eu gostaria
de ser
quais são as pessoas que eu tenho como
exemplo quais as características dessas
pessoas que eu já tenho e quase que eu
não tenha preciso desenvolver
afinal já quem está falando de seres
humanos somos seres em construção
o fato de eu não ser boa hoje alguma
coisa não quer dizer que eu nunca vai
ser boa nessa coisa o fato de ainda não
ter conseguido talvez seja só uma ainda
então olha que precisa planejar a forma
como a gente quer crescer também não
adianta só querer ficar sonhando a gente
precisa ter um planejamento e o terceiro
ponto que pra me chamou muita atenção
foi o ponto da contribuição será pensar
para pensar como é que vocês querem
contribuir porque o ser humano é um ser
que vive em comunidade então qualquer
ação nossa de alguma forma vai
influenciar as pessoas ao nosso redor e
eu vou pensar como contribuir porque eu
queria fazer mais para contribuir e
pensar no impacto
já para pensar qual é o impacto de vocês
da hora que você acorda horas que vocês
vão dormir ea mídia do tempo copa col
que vai ser esse impacto de vocês vão me
dizer que vocês forem crescendo
envelhecendo e aí quando a gente fala de
contribuição a gente fala que somos
seres que vivem juntos
então não basta eu tenho um plano de
crescimento e aprendendo e as pessoas ao
meu redor não entender muito bem disso
as pessoas ao redor não ter não sonhar e
não querendo crescer também
e aí é essa ação rescisória deve ter um
ano um pouquinho que eu parei pra
repensar isso eu só faço constantemente
essas são e mails pilares e hoje é sexta
mas dana à risca ali uma das coisas em
termos de experiência há um ano atrás eu
nem sabia que seria convidada pra mim
aqui no palco de combates
então muito curioso que conseguiram
ajudar à risca um tipo de experiência
gostaria de ver na vida vou ter que
repensar depois as próximas que eu quero
v e quando a gente fala nestes três
pilares também convido você já parou
para pensar um pouquinho que vocês
querem é como vocês querem crescer foi o
que vocês pensam que vocês querem
contribuir com a sua experiência que
vocês gostariam de viver porque é fato
que o mundo está mudando
a gente nunca interagiu do jeito que a
gente ter ágil
a gente nem sabe como que as coisas vão
mudar a saúde
as relações dos relacionamentos vamos
com a gente vive mesmo tomando tanto que
a gente não tem tempo de respirar
entender o que está acontecendo mas
concorrente pra minha vida não tem não
existe uma outra amanda graciano silva
assim começou a única vocês também são
únicos
quem tem que fazer o próprio tem que
criar um modelo de negócio de vocês são
vocês
por mais que alguém se alguém hoje está
lá alguém faça alguma coisa que vocês
ainda não fazem talvez ela tenha
começado antes ela tem os privilégios
dela ou talvez ela já tenha se preparado
um pouco mais o fato de alguém estava na
frente não quer dizer nada sobre vocês
não quer dizer que vocês são pessoas
piores e esse é o tipo de modelo mental
que faz hoje podem falar de inovação e
das grandes empresas ao mesmo modelo
mental desses empreendedores
só que não adianta a gente fazer grandes
empresas se a gente não vive uma grande
vida sem dúvida muito boa uma vida muito
bem de vida e aí um recado que eu deixo
para vocês e não deixem de ser você
não deixem a criança que tanto sonhava
morrer resgatar essa criança interior de
vocês e junto com essa criança vá
pensando em como é que vocês querem
viver a vida de vocês e siga
empreendendo porque é isso que o
empreendorismo mais o que falar de
empreendedorismo espero muito que vocês
assim como eu possam realmente vê lo
obrigada
[Música]